und jetzt hat das wort zur abgabe einer
regierungserklärung die bundeskanzlerin
dr angela merkel ich ja sehr geehrter
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
üblicherweise beschäftigt sich der
europäische rat im märz immer mit der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung und lage in
europa das wird ja auch in diesem jahr
tun aber genauso wie beim europäischen
rat im märz vergangenen jahres als
europa ja am beginn einer
weltumspannenden pandemie stand deren
wucht uns damals alle völlig neu war und
von ungeahntem ausmaß zeigt die tatsache
dass wir wieder in digitalen format
tagen werden dass die pandemie leider
bei weitem noch nicht überwunden ist
die fallzahlen steigen europaweit wieder
rapide an ich ermuntere durchaus auch
alle einmal zu schauen was in unseren
nachbarländern so los ist wenn wir über
die lage bei uns debattieren das zeigt
dass wir hier kein spezielles deutsches
phänomen beobachten sondern dass wir
doch sehr ähnliche entwicklungen in ganz
europa haben die zahlen steigen also
europaweit wieder rapide an mehr als
eine halbe million menschen haben in der
europäischen union bislang ihr leben
verloren
und der wirtschaftliche schaden ist
immens für daran erinnern nicht ganz so
weit zurück in der geschichte dass heute
vor 14 jahren am 25 märz 2007 wir in
berlin auch unter deutscher
ratspräsidentschaft im zeughaus die
erklärung unterschrieben haben die dann
zum lissabonner vertrag geführt hat und
damals bekannt haben dass wir die
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
zu unserem glück vereint sind und bei
allen beschwerlichkeiten glaube ich dass
ich in der pandemie wieder gezeigt hat
dass es gut ist dass wir diese
europäische union haben denn wenn wir
die protektionistischen tendenzen und
die weltlage uns betrachten dann glaube
ich war es richtig dass wir einer
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft doch die
weichen gestellt haben im zweiten
halbjahr 2020 für wichtige gemeinsame
europäische vorgehensweise
das ist erstens es ist erstens ganz
besonders auch für die wirtschaftliche
lage der europäische resilienz folgen
der europäische aufbau von das ist ein
nie dagewesener form und damit stellen
die mitgliedstaaten die weichen für eine
ein digitales klimafreundliches und
damit auch krisenfest des zukünftiges
europäisches wachstum hier im deutschen
bundestag steht heute die wichtige
entscheidung über die ratifizierung des
eigenmittel beschlusses an und es wird
noch einmal deutlich gesagt werden diese
aufbau von ist ein einmaliges zeitlich
und dem zweck nach eng begrenztes
instrument aber es ist ein unabdingbarer
wie ich finde beitrag dazu die pandemie
gemeinsam bewältigen zu können und
deshalb bitte ich sie für dieses
zentrale vorhaben auch um ihre
unterstützung
wir verhandeln in diesen tagen mit der
kommission über die letzten aspekte
unseres nationalen programms was wir
noch im april im kabinett verabschieden
werden und als zweiter baustein haben
wir natürlich auch in europa große
fortschritte gemacht bei der pandemie
bekämpfung selbst europäische
forscherinnen und forscher haben in
rekordzeit impfstoffe gegen kobe 19
erreger entwickelt und wir wissen üben
bei allem was noch zu tun ist das schon
heute millionen bürgerinnen und bürger
vor allen dingen auch ältere vor
schweren krankheitsverläufen geschützt
werden können dass die gründer von
biontech frau tt und erscheint gerade
vom bundespräsidenten mit dem
bundesverdienstkreuz ausgezeichnet
wurden erfüllt uns natürlich mit freude
denn deutschland hat zu dieser impfstoff
entwicklung einen wichtigen beitrag
geleistet
und bei allen beschwernissen es war
richtig auf die gemeinsame beschaffung
und zulassung von impfstoffen durch die
europäische union zu setzen wäre jetzt
sieht das selbst bei kleinen
unterschieden in den verteilungen große
diskussionen ausbrechen möchte ich mir
überhaupt nicht vorstellen wenn einige
mitgliedstaaten impfstoffe hätten andere
nicht es würde den binnenmarkt in seinen
grundfesten erschüttern und deshalb
glaube ich dass wir die grundlagen
gelegt haben um diese größte
bewährungsprobe der europäischen union
auch gut zu bestehen aber es ist noch
viel zu tun und es gehört zu den
wahrheiten dass diese pandemie uns auch
gezeigt hat wo wir schonungslos
sozusagen analysieren müssen wo unsere
schwächen liegen und das wird uns auch
auf diesem europäischen rat beschäftigen
denn es wird um die digitalisierung
gehen neben der beschäftigung mit der
türkei und der bekämpfung der pandemie
wir wissen dass europa in der krise
weder erstaunen noch verharren darf
sondern dass wir die herausforderungen
annehmen müssen und da ist der digitale
wandel von zentraler bedeutung auch für
deutschland haben wir ja unsere
schwächen erkannt
wir haben in einem gemeinsamen brief mit
den ministerpräsidentinnen von dänemark
finnland und island einen eindringlichen
appell an die kommission verfasst dem
sich inzwischen viele weitere eu staaten
angeschlossen haben dass europa seine
digitale souveränität entschlossen
umsetzt es geht hier ums tempo es geht
nicht nur um das wie sondern es geht
auch um das wann und dabei bedeutet
digitale souveränität nicht dass wir
alles alleine machen werden aber es
bedeutet dass europa als teil einer
globalisierten welt in einem freien und
regelbasierten markt seine fähigkeiten
und kapazitäten zusammen mit seinen
partnern ausbauen muss und dass wir
antworten geben müssen auf die frage wo
müssen wir besser werden wo sind wir
heute schon gut wo bestehen risikoreiche
abhängigkeiten
und wo wollen wir als letzte option auch
eigene europäische kapazitäten aufbauen
um resident zu sein und gerade im
bereich der impfstoffe ist das ein punkt
aber eben auch im bereich der digitalen
zu wenig souveränität und jetzt müssen
vorschläge erarbeitet werden die das
gesamte instrumentarium des
binnenmarktes ausschöpfen und zwar aus
der perspektive unseres verständnisses
einer menschlichen wirtschaftsordnung
bei der der mensch im mittelpunkt steht
es muss also um eine verantwortungsvolle
und werte geleitete europäische
digitalwirtschaft geben bei der wir
sagen wo wir eigene akzente setzen
wollen und insofern erwarten wir von der
kommission vorschläge für die digitalen
identitäten und einen europäischen
rechtsrahmen für die künstliche
intelligenz und auch einen regelungswerk
für online plattform wobei wir davon
ausgehen dass wir hier auch globale
initiativen als europäische union
ergreifen sollten denn globale denn
digitale plattformen zu regulieren
allein in europa wird auch nicht geben
meine damen und herren wir haben dann
als zweiten punkt die beziehungen der
europäischen union zur türkei und die
lage im östlichen mittelmeer
sie wissen einen blick vor europas
haustür nordafrika syrien die ukraine
zeigt dass wir von 4c lligen
konfliktherden umgeben sind und
gleichzeitig wissen wir dass das
gedeihen und der wohlstand in der eu nur
mit guten beziehungen unsere
nachbarschaft auch außerhalb der
europäischen union möglich sind und das
gilt in ganz besonderer weise auch für
das nato mitglied türkei in seinen
vielschichtigen beziehungen und der
außenbeauftragte josef borel hat hier
einen umfassenden bericht vorgelegt der
dieser vielschichtigkeit der beziehungen
auch gerecht wird
es ist erst mal eine gute nachricht dass
die türkei nach dem produzierenden
aktivitäten in zyklischen und
griechischen gewässern in den letzten
monaten ein zeichen der deeskalation im
östlichen mittelmeerraum gesetzt hat und
in den dialog mit griechenland wieder
eingetreten ist auch die 5 plus 1
gespräche unter der ägide der vereinten
aktionen über die zukunft zyperns werden
fortgesetzt im europäischen rat hatten
wir vereinbart dass wir im fall einer
entspannung von seiten der türkei
weitere optionen für eine gemeinsame
zusammenarbeit anbieten
und jetzt werden wir auf diesem rat
diskutieren wie wir auf diesem weg
weitergehen
ich sag gleich vorweg das werden keine
einfachen gespräche aber ich hoffe dass
wir zu einem ergebnis kommen die türkei
ist nicht nur nato partner und
verbündete sondern als unser
unmittelbarer nachbar und das zweite
bevölkerungsreichste land an der
eu-außengrenze natürlich von
strategischer wichtigkeit
wir deutschen haben ganz besonders enge
beziehungen zur türkei
da in deutschland viele türkischstämmige
menschen seit generationen leben
aber wir haben natürlich auf der anderen
seite auch die innenpolitische situation
in der türkei in den blick zu nehmen und
wir erwarten dass die türkei
rechtsstaatliche standards einhält und
das an vielen stellen nicht der fall
auch menschenrechte werden nicht
respektiert in vielen fällen und die
istanbul konvention des europarates dass
die türkei hier ausgetreten ist ist ein
sehr sehr bedauerlich es zeichen und wir
hätten uns gewünscht dass die türkei
hier mitglied bleibt aber ich denke es
ist brauch richtig sprachlosigkeit in
den beziehungen zur türkei hilft uns
nicht weiter
und deshalb wollen wir darüber beraten
wie wir hochrangige dialoge zwischen der
europäischen union und der türkei wieder
aufnehmen können wir haben gemeinsame
interessen und die besondere
herausforderung der migration gehört
hier dazu
diese können wir nur gemeinsam mit der
türkei lösen und das verfasst das vor
fast genau fünf jahren vereinbarte eu
türkei abkommen oder die erklärung ist
genau die grundlage dafür die
weiterentwickelt werden ich weiß dass es
viel kritik an dieser erklärung gibt
aber trotz aller kritik können wir
feststellen dass auf diesem wege viel
gutes erreicht wurde
es ist uns gelungen das
menschenverachtende geschäft der
schlosser wirksam zu bekämpfen
die zahl der illegalen grenze
dort drehte nach griechenland ist
zurückgegangen und das gleiche gilt auch
für die zahl der todesopfer in der ägäis
dank der unterstützung durch die
europäische union können 660.000
syrische flüchtlingskinder in der türkei
zur schule gehen über 14 millionen
arztbesuche konnten durchgeführt werden
über 1,8 millionen menschen haben in
einer sehr schwierigen zeit zusätzliche
unterstützung für ihren lebensunterhalt
bekommen
dabei ist es wichtig zu betonen dass die
eu gelder über die arbeit der
verschiedenen projekte und
organisationen vor ort den bedürftigen
zu gute kommen ihr einsatz wird in der
der gelder wird in der eu überprüft und
ich meine das sind im namen der
mitmenschlichkeit gut angelegte mittel
und die fortführung dieser
zusammenarbeit ist im beiderseitigen
interesse
die türkei hat stand heute 3,6 millionen
syrische flüchtlinge aufgenommen das
entspricht der einwohnerzahl berlins
daher ist mir wichtig zu betonen dass
die der türkei für das geleistete hohe
anerkennung berührt und deshalb setze
ich mich dafür ein dass wir die neuen
die eu türkei erklärung neu beleben und
auch fortentwickeln
meine damen und herren abschließend
möchte ich nun auch das dritte große und
uns ja auch alle täglich beschäftigen
die thema zu sprechen kommen europas
bewältigung der pandemie wir werden uns
über die nächsten schritte bei der
entwicklung eines sogenannten grid
digitalen grünen zertifikaten was bis
zum sommer vorliegen soll
und mit dem es möglich sein soll eu-weit
zu dokumentieren ob eine person geimpft
oder getestet wurde
parallel dazu hat die europäische
kommission ihre arbeiten an der
technischen umsetzbarkeit aufgenommen
genauso die nationalstaaten deutschland
hier auch das ist keine leichte aufgabe
weil 27 mitgliedsstaaten und wird uns
noch einige wochen in anspruch nehmen
denn wir werden ja sehr genau schauen
müssen welche rechte mit diesem
zertifikat verbunden sind die technische
umsetzung ist relativ einfach aber diese
frage ist natürlich von großer
wichtigkeit
meine damen und herren wir werden
darüber sprechen wie wir auch europaweit
unabhängiger werden und
dazu gehört vor allen dingen auch die
frage der impfstoffproduktion die
kommission hat weit über die jetzigen
bestellungen hinaus eine task force
eingesetzt genauso wie wir national um
sicherzustellen dass wir auch in zukunft
ausreichend impfstoffe innerhalb der
europäischen union bestellen können denn
das problem im augenblick mit der
impfstoffversorgung liegt weniger in der
frage wie viel bestellt wurde sondern
der frage wie viel kann auf europäischen
grund im augenblick gefertigt werden
denn wir sehen ganz genau britische
fertigungsstätten fertigen für
großbritannien die vereinigten staaten
exportieren nicht und deshalb sind wir
darauf angewiesen was kann in europa
produziert werden und wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass dieses virus uns noch
lange mit seinen mutationen beschäftigen
kann
das heißt die frage geht weit über
dieses jahr hinaus
und wir haben einen zweiten punkt in den
blick zu nehmen und deshalb können wir
gar nicht genug impfstoff produzieren in
europa nämlich die versorgung mit der
welt wenn uns das nicht gelingt werden
wir immer wieder mit mutationen
konfrontiert werden die dann auch die
gefahr mit sich bringen dass
anschließend die impfstoffe nicht mehr
wirksam sind und deshalb müssen wir uns
darum kümmern und das bedeutet und das
bedeutet natürlich auch dass wir hier zu
hause bei uns hart zu arbeiten haben
heute vor einem jahr lag die fallzahl
von kona infizierten in deutschland bei
nach angaben des robert koch instituts
bei 4.100 18 19 heute bei 22 1675 die
inzidenz war damals 35 und es gab 35
neue todesfälle
heute ist die inzidenz 113,3 und es gibt
2 128 neue todesfälle über 56 über
75.000 menschen sind inzwischen in
deutschland an cupid 19 gestorben
und wenn wir uns dieses jahr noch einmal
anschauen dann liegt nach einem scharfen
dauern am anfang der pannen im rückblick
relativ leicht an
guten das sommer steigende werte im
herbst und dann in stufen von shutdowns
immer wieder die schließung vieler
einrichtungen und dann auch die
absenkung der inzidenz und dann ist es
jetzt muss man sagen sind wir in der
dritten welle und wieder im
exponentiellen wachstum
viele menschen fragen mit recht waren
nun alles umsonst geht das immer so
weiter und dass ich verstehe diese bange
frage viele wert vieler betroffener
eltern mit kindern oder kita mit
schulkindern oder kita kindern
geschäftsinhaber und restaurantbesitzer
veranstaltungswirtschaft sportvereine
und vieles vieles mehr
die antwort kann ich aus vor allem aus
voller überzeugung geben nein
die situation ist eine ganz andere als
im letzten jahr
auch wenn wir in der weihnachtszeit
einen schweren rückschlag erfahrung
haben und dieser rückschlag war nicht
voraussehen war als wir im november
dezember die einschränkende maßnahmen
machen konnten
und das ist das auftreten der britischen
mutation eine mutation des alten
ursprünglichen virus hat jetzt die
oberhand gewonnen
wir leben im grunde in einer neuen
pandemie und die wirkung des
ursprünglichen shutdowns denn wer das
alte virus hätte wäre heute so dass wir
überall und deutschlandweit deutlich
unter 50 bei der incidents liegen würden
das tun wir aber leider nicht weil diese
mutation aggressiver ist infektiöser und
um einen ziemlich großen betrag
tödlicher das heißt der faktor ist
wieder über 1 gestiegen und wir sind
wieder in der phase des exponentiellen
wachstums was können wir jetzt tun und
was haben wir an anderen instrumenten in
der hand um mit neuen möglichkeiten auch
zu reagieren
erstens wir haben wird gemeinsam mit dem
ministerpräsidenten ein öffnungs konzept
am dritten märz beschlossen dass ein
viel höheres maß an regionalisierung
enthält es sagt ganz deutlich in welchen
regionen geöffnet werden
und wir sehen ja auch dass einige
bundesländer wenn ich an saarland denke
welche und schleswig-holstein denke
diese möglichkeiten auch richtig nutzen
wir haben sechs landkreise noch im
augenblick die unter 35 liegen beide
institute 24 landkreise unter 50 144
landkreise unter 100 und der rest
darüber und es wäre falsch alle
sozusagen mit einem maßstab zu belegen
und das widerspiegelt auch unser
öffnungs konzept wir haben die
möglichkeit des testens und zwar in viel
einfacher form als uns das mit den pcr
tests von heute vor einem jahr zur
verfügung stand die alten die gehen
schnelltests und vor allen dingen die
selbst ermöglichen neues herangehen wir
haben das auf eine test strategie
besprochen die auf drei säulen
beschlossen die auf drei säulen ruht
einmal auf den bürger testzentren die
inzwischen ziemlich flächendeckend in
der gesamten bundesrepublik deutschland
aufgebaut sind und ich würde an dieser
stelle einmal sagen wir sind ein
föderaler staat
es ist keinem oberbürgermeister und
keinem landrat verwehrt das zu tun was
in tübingen und rostock getan wird alle
können das macht und der bund wird immer
unterstützt
tätig sein wir als grund ermöglichen sie
mit ihren beschlüssen ermöglichen dass
sich jeder bürger mindestens einmal in
der woche testen lassen kann
ich fordere und bitte alle bürgerinnen
und bürger das in dieser
augenblicklichen situation auch zu tun
wenn man sich zu hause trifft wenn man
sich mit jemandem getroffen hat das ist
ein wichtiges mittel und es kostenlos
für jeden verfügbar
und so wie ich mir berichten lassen auch
organisatorisch sehr sehr gut gemacht
zweitens schulen und kita wir haben wir
in einer logistikplattform ich habe da
gestern darüber gesprochen mit den
ländern eine testtags force gebildet es
sind bestellungen aufgegeben worden von
den ländern für kitas und schulen und
ist von allen bundesländern gesagt
worden es sind jetzt ausreichend es
bestellt für die monate märz und april
nicht setzen trotz habe ich gestern mit
dem bundesgesundheitsminister noch mal
gesprochen und gesagt sichert euch
marktanteile für die selbst wenn
irgendeine neue situation entsteht wenn
jemand sagt ich brauche doch noch mehr
aber ich sage auch ganz offen für 40.000
schulen und tausende von kitas kann der
bund nicht von berlin aus die test
infrastruktur vorhalten sondern dafür
haben wir eine föderale und wenn uns
jemand fragt wo können wir helfen dann
tun wir das gerne die bundeswehr hat
schon an so vielen stellen
wir tun es gerne aber wir können ist
nicht alles organisatorisch umsetzen und
der dritte punkt ist die der dritte teil
der säule ist die ist der arbeitsplatz
wir wissen dass auch hier viele
infektionen stattfinden und deshalb
haben wir eine selbstverpflichtung mit
der wirtschaft ab gemacht aber die endet
ende märz anfang april dann wollen wir
ein klares monitoring- haben dann wollen
wir wären wir werden eigene erhebungen
machen und denn wer nicht der wehr nicht
der überwiegende teil der deutschen
wirtschaft und das sind nicht irgendwie
ist 65 prozent sondern 70 sondern das
muss in ihrem liebsten von 90 prozent
seien test seinen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern anbietet dann werden wir
mit regulatorischen maßnahmen in der
arbeitsschutzverordnung dazu vorgehen
und das wird im kabinett am 13 april
entschieden werden weil wir in der woche
nach ostern dann den status machen und
dann muss da klarheit sein
ich sage allerdings auch die besten
testangebote nutzen nichts wenn sie
nicht wahrgenommen werden wenn ich aus
schulen aus betrieben höre dass nur 30
40 prozent der möglichkeiten genutzt
werden
dann hilft uns das nicht und testen ist
die brücke hin bis wir die impf wirkung
sehen und deshalb kann jeder bürger und
jede bürgerin auch einen beitrag dazu
leisten indem man von den test angeboten
mit gebrauch macht und wie mehr wir
testen um so weniger müssen wir
einschreiten aber und wir haben
zusätzlich um die regionalisierung noch
einmal zu unterstreichen für jedes
bundesland vereinbart dass
modellprojekte jetzt durchgeführt werden
können die kommunen sind in einer können
das tun und die bundesländer haben jetzt
auch vorschläge gemacht in welcher form
das gemacht wird wir werden diese diese
versuche dann auswerten
aber meine einschätzung ist folgende
solange die infektionszahlen
einigermaßen noch im griff sind
meinetwegen auch noch kurz über 100
liegen die incident kann man mit dem
testen noch sehr viel erreichen wenn man
einmal sehr viel höher als wir einnehmen
ganz steilen exponentiellen anstieg ist
dann müssen eben doch wieder
beschränkende regeln eingeführt werden
und je stärker der anstieg ist umso mehr
das heißt wir können auf begrenzende
regeln im augenblick noch nicht ganz
verzichten und deshalb haben wir neben
der notbremse die wir miteinander
vereinbart haben in der eröffnungs
strategie auch ganz klar gesagt mit den
bundesländern es können zusätzliche
maßnahmen eingeführt werden hier gibt es
gewaltige politische unterschiede was
man für geeignet hält und was nicht das
gehört zur vielfalt eines föderalen
systems dazu entscheiden ist ja auch nur
die wirkung
ich kann weitere kontakt beschränkungen
machen wie daniel günther das in
flensburg gemacht hat ich kann ausgangs
beschränkungen machen wie das bayern und
baden württemberg gemacht haben in
bestimmten regionen aber in bestimmten
situationen kann ich nicht nichts machen
dann sehe ich zu wie schrittweise die
überlastung des gesundheitssystems
wieder in den blick kommt und ich habe
jetzt über die ganzen möglichkeiten
gesprochen die wir haben und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen alles an
fallzahlen bedeutet auch wenn jetzt die
älteren mit der ganz hohen risiko gruppe
nicht mehr so dabei sind weil sie
geimpft sind und immunisiert sind aber
alles bedeutet zum schluss den anstieg
von belegten intensivbetten in deutschen
krankenhäusern und wenn bei der frage
die wir jetzt vorgehen der oster
lockdown einzig und allein eine wirklich
positive resonanz bei dem
intensivmediziner gefunden hat dann
sehen sie wie groß dort die sorge und es
werden jetzt nicht mehr 90 jährige seien
in den krankenhäusern liegen es werden
50 60 und 70 jährige sein und das sind
menschen mit sehr vielen jahren
lebenserwartung und 10% zu sagen uns die
experten werden langzeitfolgen von
corona davontragen das heißt es lohnt
sich um jeden zu kämpfen dass er die
infektion nicht bekommt und das ist
unsere gemeinsame aufgabe möglichst viel
freiheit für jeden mit möglichst vielen
normalität für jeden aber auch mit
möglichst viel rücksicht darauf dass
nicht tausende von menschen noch sterben
müssen
und das muss die muss das ziel sein für
die nächsten wochen
und dann liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
natürlich ist das impfen
der weg aus der krise und wir kriegen
jetzt sukzessive mehr impfstoff und ich
sage ganz offen die im testzentrum
machen eine gute arbeit aber wenn
irgendwo impftermine möglich werden und
eine dosis impfstoff vorhanden ist und
er nicht wahrgenommen wird dieser termin
weil keiner vergeben ist dann ist das
nicht in ordnung und dann müssen wir
besser werden
der bund muss sagen wo er besser wird
und die länder müssen sagen wo sie
besser werden und die kommunen müssen
sagen wo wir bessern wenn wir uns
ausruhen auf dem was wir haben reicht es
nicht
wir brauchen die impfzentren da wird
tolle arbeit geleistet es will ich
ausdrücklich sagen aber wo man noch
schneller werden kann und flexibler muss
man es wären und wir werden ab der woche
nach ostern auch die hausärzte mit
einbeziehen das sind 50.000 praxen die
werden beliefert und mit aufsteigender
tendenz und im mai werde man dann auch
über die betriebsärzte reden aber wir
werden alle brauchen um die impfstoffe
zu für impfen es wäre dramatisch wenn
uns das nicht gelingen würde deshalb
widmen wir den sehr viel aufmerksamkeit
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die monate der pandemie
haben gravierende schwachstellen im
funktionieren unseres gemeinschafts
wesens offengelegt dass die
digitalisierung auf der bundesebene ist
ob das die vernetzung der durch digitale
möglichkeiten ich sage nur das stichwort
sommers mit den gesundheitsämtern ist
wir müssen als föderales system hier
besser und schneller werden das wissen
wir
und daran wird auch gearbeitet und da
können sie schreien und noch was machen
wir müssen etwas tun es nützlich den
ganzen tag zu kritisieren und wir sehr
wohnt der bund tut etwas wir haben mit
viel anstrengung jetzt erreicht dass die
allermeisten bundesländer viel zu spät
aber sich doch dem sommer system
anschließen
wir haben eine corona warm up von der in
deutschland kein einziges
positives wort zu hören ist wenn ich es
mal so gross und module nehme ich will
nur sagen 17 europäischen ländern
arbeiten und leben mit dieser corona
warne und die deutsche wahl hat ist dort
nicht bekannt als eine besonders
unflexible in finnland sind fast alle
bürgerinnen und bürger dabei ich kann
nur sagen an die bürgerinnen und bürger
gewandt auch nutzen sie auch diese
corona warm und es ist zur zeit
vielleicht eine stimmung bei der wir nur
dass kritische sieht und deshalb möchte
ich einfach zum ende meiner rede auch
noch einmal sagen es gibt millionen von
menschen die sich jeden tag gegen diese
pandemie stemmen und ihre arbeit leisten
und zwar mit großem einsatz das sind die
pflegerinnen das sind die ärzte das sind
die lehrer das sind die eltern das sind
die ehrenamtlichen und das sind die
menschen in den tests und im zentrum
viele sind beruflich neue wege gegangen
mit schweren beschwerden veränderungen
in ihrem leben ich weiß wie schwer es
viele haben aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen man kann auch nichts erreichen
wenn man immer nur das negative sieht
nicht umsonst hatten sich erst gesagt es
ist entscheidend ob das glas halb voll
oder halb leer
und wenn es immer nur halb leer ist dann
werden wir auch keine kreative kraft als
land entwickeln um aus dieser krise
herauskommen und ich sage ihnen mit dem
impfen haben wir den möglichkeiten in
der hand und es wird noch einige monate
dauern aber das licht am ende des
tunnels sichtbar
wir werden dieses virus besiegen und
deshalb nicht ganz sicher dass wir das
schaffen werden und deshalb geht es
jetzt darum die kraft zu bündeln und
positiv nach vorne zu schauen
auch wenn die situation im augenblick
schwierig ist das ist das was ich mir
wünsche von jedem und jeder in diesem
land herzlichen
[Applaus]